I'm here with a very special guest at
the moment this is someone
I get asked about more than anyone else
I've worked with
in late night Wherever I Go
wherever I go in the world
uh probably once a day people come up to
me and say
what's the deal with Jordan schlansky he
is a phenomenon so I thought I'd have
Jordan come in sit down and maybe we'd
talk about this and see if we can't
figure out
uh what this relationship is uh really
all about so sitting here is George
Lansky hello Jordan hi
are you close enough to the microphone
you have to tell me that's not my
responsibility okay well why don't you
put the microphone a little closer to
your mouth
you are being an incredible prick
already I didn't realize it was
functioning as an audio engineer but I'm
happy to comply okay I'm not an audio
engineer but I could tell immediately I
don't know how these are calibrated
you've been in this studio many times
this is my first appearance okay you if
you're listening right now and you're
driving and you're uh clenching the
wheel angrily uh I apologize that's
because
like me when someone comes on and takes
an arrogant
inhuman tone you get upset why would you
assume I know how many inches this is
meant to be from my mouth that's like
quite an assumption that's a great Point
how many inches is this from my mouth
you just opened yourself up to I mean if
the Impractical Jokers right now were on
the line they'd be having a blast you
how many inches is this from my mouth
Jordan let's get started before you get
combative or strange please answer these
questions succinctly how did you come to
work for me do you remember the year I
do the year was 1994. I was an unpaid
intern initially and then I was hired to
continue my employment okay so you
started out as an intern and then some
idiot decided to hire you on
permanently and you were paid and then
eventually you got a title on the show
which was
oh I don't remember what I started at
there were news titles yes I'm sure
there were numerous what was the title
you ended up with associate producer
right man if there's ever been a vague
term uh it would have to be associate
producer because we started using you on
the show and when I say using you I mean
featuring you as a personality because
you're so unusual I think it was uh
Frank Smiley I'll give Frank Smiley the
credit Frank's my longtime producer on
our show said Jordan's fascinating we
need to get him on camera I thought that
was kind of immoral you know uh in a way
to take advantage of someone with your
limitations and exploit you but Frank
was determined and we did and so I I
also blame Frank for empowering you
um Frank do Frank's here by the way
Frank well do you remember
um Jordan worked on the show and then
you one day said uh we got to get this
guy on on camera well I mean
it was an easy softball for you to hit
out of the park every time because we
had this relationship and it wasn't
being recorded yes the relationship that
people see in these remotes was
basically going on in the office every
single day yes and people think oh is
this an act no it's not an act because
it was going on for several years before
we you even thought to put this on
camera that's right it was during the
writer's strike when we were desperate
for
um material that wasn't that didn't need
any writing yeah you just needed me and
Jordan in a room together and stuff
would start to happen right because he
so naturally
um provocative yes there's nobody like
Jordan and
um
he's a strange man yeah and uh it um you
know it's obvious that America loves him
yeah America has taken you to its
Collective bosom I do mean bosom Jordan
I swear to God almost every day people
ask me what's the deal with Jordan my
son loves in and out the In-N-Out
hamburger chain here in California
and a bunch of years ago we're passing
one and my son is really hungry and he
says hey can we go to In and Out and I
say sure thing so we pull over into the
parking lot and my son goes into place
his order
and uh uh I'm standing outside the car
a truck a semi truck screeches to a halt
the driver puts it in neutral and puts
on the emergency brake jumps out and
runs across the highway
and says to me I just have to know is
Jordan real
that's the kind of I mean he this guy
thre he put his life in danger to find
out if you are real I still don't have
the answer I still don't know exactly
what you did on our show what does an
associate producer do what was your job
what did you do for us why did we pay
you uh well across the entertainment
industry the title associate producer is
somewhat variable I had a multitude of
responsibilities geared towards the
smooth operation of the show okay again
what a cloud of nonsense well I could
tell you uh what one of my
responsibilities was not and that was
not to explain to you what I do okay oh
okay so that was not your job let me
explain to people listening right now
if you're familiar at all with the
defense mechanisms behind a modern
nuclear sub here's how it works if it's
attacked what happens is that the the
enemy ship fires a torpedo at it that
homes in on the large metallic structure
that is the sub as it gets close one of
the things that the sub that's being
attacked can do is it can shoot out a
lot of metal shards and junk out of the
side and that distracts the missile so
it veers off and attacks the space the
junk that's been emitted and doesn't hit
the actual sub that's what you do every
time I ask you what do you do for a job
you open your mouth and you eject a
bunch of and it misdirects the
question uh the question explodes
harmlessly often the Briny deep and your
sub is saved and you you seem to take
pride in your own ignorance as to my
responsibilities as if this is something
you should be bragging about not
understanding what your employees do
it's not my responsibility to explain to
you it's a belabor every detail of what
I do what the real question is what are
you doing right now
what are you doing to fill your time I'm
doing a Serious XM do you realize what
an honor it is to get channel 106. do
you know what was on channel 106 before
I took it over do you consider this a
full-time occupation I don't know I'm
really enjoying it and I think you're
just bitter that you're not able to skim
uh any of your own cashola off my off my
Sirius XM gig I think you're angry that
you can't be associate producer of
SiriusXM channel 106. I'm indifferent
I'm here to ask the question answer the
questions that you asked me well I love
it when different people start shouting
at me
I'm completely indifferent